thousands of nevadans also continue to
struggle paying for housing during the
pandemic
there is help available through our
state's eviction moratorium but a lot of
people need financial assistance right
now
erko mana joining us now live with how
one local apartment complex got help
from one of its own
orco
well denise countless nevadans have lost
their jobs or have
reduced incomes because of the pandemic
which can make
paying rent extremely difficult that's
why one local property manager is
stepping up
to help her tenants i can't let all
these people
just lose their home fighting back tears
las vegas property manager tiffany
mcneely issues a plea to the public
she posted this video to facebook last
month trying to help her tenants
18 of them at risk of getting evicted i
just felt that there was a need
and that i needed to speak out about it
to get change here within the community
mcneely tells me within a matter of days
her apartment complex raised more than
65 thousand dollars through private
donations and money from community
organizations
it's just been a really exciting time
for us pure joy
seen in this update video because those
tenants got to stay
put i was ecstatic i could not even
contain myself when the checks started
rolling in
but these acts of kindness don't always
happen and nevada's eviction moratorium
now extended through the end of march
is not automatic that's why the legal
aid center of southern nevada says it's
up to the renter to take action
you have to sign a declaration you have
to give it to your landlord and you have
to keep some proof
of how you deliver that to your landlord
another issue is that financial
assistance applications through chap
are not being processed fast enough
that's why mcneely is just getting
started
the work is not over i still am reaching
out to people who are looking to be
donors
now the legal aid center of southern
nevada also tells me that
if you get an eviction notice even if
you've already submitted your moratorium
declaration form
you must respond to that eviction notice
and file something in the courts
reporting live in las vegas tonight orco
mana 8 news now